this morning the Vatican summit on
clergy misconduct is focusing on senior
Catholic officials who ignored sex abuse
cases
the Archbishop of Chicago Cardinal blaze
supid told bishops the church should
reject cover-ups created out of fear of
legal issues or scandal he spoke after
the Chicago archdiocese admitted quote a
very small number of priests have
fathered children and four remain
priests in the Archdiocese Niki batiste
spoke with Cardinal supac yesterday
she's in Rome with the interview you'll
see only on CBS this morning
Niki good morning Gail good morning
the archdiocese tells us the last time a
priest fathered a child was nearly 20
years ago and that each child was
provided financial support through
college age that revelation came after
we interviewed Cardinal su pitch and he
did not address it this morning the
church as a loving mother must
continually open herself to the
heartbreaking reality of children whose
wounds will never heal before speaking
to nearly 200 Catholic leaders at a
summit on clergy sex abuse the
Archbishop of Chicago Cardinal a supe
j-- sat down with us how's the summit
going so far the the meeting really I
think was off to a good start where the
Holy Father had a very I think very
strong introduction welcoming people and
then giving the number of points in
which he wanted us to look at as we move
forward some of those reflection points
the Pope provided establishing specific
protocols for handling accusations
against bishops and creating groups
comprised of both clerics and laypeople
for victims who want to report any
crimes it's clear to me that where the
Holy Father is going on this and what
I'm hearing for the other bishops is
that there are going to be concrete
procedures concrete steps I tried to say
no that's what dozens of survivors who
follow the bishops to Rome are looking
for to Manning the church adopt reforms
to punish not only priests who abuse
children but also bishops who cover it
up is that cover-up more of a focus this
time around here the Holy Father has
made it very clear that if someone
mishandles us even if it's not out of
malice or their fault objectively if
they mess it
they are going to be risking being
removed from office at the summit church
leaders watched video testimony from
several survivors I don't think there
was a person in the room who did not
feel a sense of urgency but also
discussed at what they said supid spoke
with other victims privately how was
your meeting with the 12 survivors it
was very enlightening I encouraged them
to keep speaking we need to hear their
voices there are the ones who have got
us here the summit is expected to end on
Sunday but Cardinal sue pitch tells CBS
News the Pope asked him and the
organising committee to stay a few extra
days
he says that's when they'll meet with
senior Vatican officials to discuss
those concrete measures the Pope wants
Nora glad to hear they're spending extra
time Nikki Batista in Rome thank you